foreign
so when I first started studying autism
you know 20 years ago
it was very narrowly defined as a
disease there was only five or six
different genes that had been implicated
in causing autism it was incredibly
highly inherited so you know if we can
give a heritability score for different
diseases and different inheritance
patterns hair color and eye color might
give you a heritability score of one
whereas something like cervical cancer
which is caused by a virus you know has
a heritability score of closer to zero
okay and autism had a heritability score
of something like .96 so very very
highly heritable and it made it
different from almost all of the other
Neuropsychiatric diseases out there
because
things like depression and anxiety or
hovering more around the 0.5 range so
sometimes inherited sometimes
environmental usually a combination of
those factors right and at the time that
diagnosis was so narrowly defined that
you got this high heritability and then
for a variety of different reasons some
of them scientific some of them
socioeconomic the definition of autism
got expanded and so there in the
diagnostic and statistical manual
of Neuropsychiatric disease the expanded
definition started including the
spectrum of autism and so now rather
than having you know you absolutely have
to have an impairment in social
behaviors and an impairment in locomotor
stereotypes and all of these other
developmental criteria it sort of got
expanded and and a lot more things
started being included and when this
happened
the
heritability estimates of the disease
dropped and so my interpretation of
those data is that basically we stopped
defining a disease that was a sort of
unified single disease and started
including a lot more things that were
not what I would consider to be
classical autism and so now it feels
like to me that this has gotten so
expansive that we're essentially
including things like
ADHD with social anxiety or all kinds of
other things that while they might be in
the realm of autism it makes it much
harder to identify it and say this is
what's being caused and as a scientist I
find this to be something that makes my
life much more difficult if we are no
longer defining the disease in a very
narrow way and so when this happens it's
a little bit frustrating and so I have
tended to focus on those early
identified genes like fmr1 which have
you know have been known to be a cause
of autism for a long time and more
importantly when we look at all of the
other genes that have been implicated in
autism so now we're somewhere in the
approximately a thousand genes have been
implicated in autism
fmr1 seems to be a node so in other
words the protein that fmr1 encodes
regulates roughly 2 25 percent of all
the other autism genes right and so to
me that's a good place to start to try
and understand autism and then I will
leave it up to the epidemiologist to
sort out how to redefine the category so
that we're capturing
the right subset of patients and
excluding the subset that are not going
to respond to therapy if we're targeting
the subset that are defined in one
specific way